hey everyone welcome back for a new
exclusive Collider interview I am beyond
thrilled to have Matthew Hyneman the
director of a private war on the set
right now first off welcome thanks for
having me before I even ask you about
your movie I just have to say this is
something else and it it's kind of
eating away at me I was just talking
about it with some other clatter
employees before that it doesn't feel
like it's getting a far enough reach yet
I want to get people talking about this
and especially Rosamund Pike's
performance in this like how is that not
getting more recognition right now it's
very frustrating to me I couldn't agree
more
yeah so clearly we're gonna celebrate
that and hopefully spread the word out
there but first thing I want to ask you
because you're obviously a very
acclaimed documentary director is what
came first this story and this script or
the idea to make your first narrative
feature you know I think a lot of
documentary filmmakers do so as a sort
of a gateway drug to make narratives not
a lot of it's but some do and and for me
you know I know sort of master-planned
I'm making narratives I've loved making
Docs I'll continue to make Docs
I made a phone called cartel land and
afterwards I guess some people thought I
should be making narratives and so I got
sent a bunch of scripts none of which I
wanted to make and then I received an
early draft of this script and it just
spoke to me in to profound way that I
felt like I had to tell this story well
it sounds like a very similar situation
people could be in even when they make a
first feature that is a narrative that
takes off and all of a sudden you're
getting every opportunity in the world
because you made one good film it sounds
like it's a it could be a very similar
path there yeah I mean you know I I
don't know you know I wouldn't have made
any any narrative film I mean that's
again this this film was was deeply
personal to me it's about a world that
I've lived in it's been a world that I
know
you know my mom was a journalist and you
know it's where I grew up in and so it
just yeah it just felt like I something
that spoke to me in such a strong way
and also was incredibly timely you know
in this world where journalism is under
attack and and media is under attack you
know I think it's so important to
celebrate people like Marie who are out
there fighting for the truth and you
know shedding light on dark corners of
the world it's really refreshing getting
a story in that respect but also because
nowadays were constantly on social media
and it feels like the kind of news I
ingest more often and before I even
shift it to film I was a journalism
major and I had a great appreciation for
long-form storytelling an immersive
storytelling so it's especially
refreshing getting that experience
through her eyes in this movie versus
let's say you know a twitter news brief
that's X amount of characters yeah I
mean I think she believed like I believe
you know that it's it's so easy for
people to keep these conflicts at arm's
length it's so easy to not engage so
easy to sort of you know read a stat or
look at a photo or look at a headline
and feel like you understand an issue
and you know I've tried as much as
possible in my documentaries to take
these issues that are so complex and you
know and and try to humanize them and in
an effort to just create a little bit of
empathy to get people to care and that's
what she did for two plus decades and
two most dangerous places on earth I
also can't speak for everybody but it
also seems like you know documentary
filmmaking in this kind of reporting
that forces you to not only just respond
to it immediately but take it with you
versus let's say just clicking a like
button or sharing and then moving on
with your life take it with you and take
it with you like personally like really
just have a much fuller understanding
and have it on your mind yeah I mean I
you know that's that's what she tried to
do and I guess in some sort of
Medicine's you know we're trying to do
with this film is it and get people to
care about the issues that that she
covered and
obviously tragically were the film ends
in Syria you know that that's that's an
issue that I had you know she she was
killed in 2012 and you know
unfortunately and sadly and tragically
that issue is persisted until to this
day you know 500,000 plus civilians have
been killed
since she was killed and I think if she
were alive today she'd probably be an
illiberal else still telling that story
I wanted to ask you a little bit about
the framing device of the story - the
idea of having the title card that says
X amount of years until Homs was that
something that was in the script right
from when you got it or is that
something that came up naturally as you
went along or maybe even in the Edit
room it's something something that you
know when I came on board you know I was
really moved by the script but I spent
about a year researching like I'd
research a doc gaining the trust of her
friends and her colleagues with Rosamond
you know reading everything I could
about her reading everything that I
could that she wrote working with Marie
Brenner the Vanity Fair journalist who
wrote the original article on which this
the script is based and then using all
that research to dig in with a rational
are screen writer you know to really
restructure the film and take it away
from sort of a biopic and make it much
more in my mind a psychological thriller
of trying to understand what drives
somebody to go to these places what
drives somebody to do this but also the
effect that this had on her
psychologically and you know obviously
from the PTSD that she she suffered from
you told me about approaching this as
one a truthful telling of her story but
also understanding the requirement that
you are adapting a story to to film and
that's a different medium and you need
to have yeah I guess I have to say
entertainment value to it a little bit
so where were you able to find that
balance was it difficult to kind of
pinpoint where that should be
[Music]
I don't know I mean there's someone's
inherent drama and her story and and
what she went through and what she
covered I think you know I think that
the hardest part was was was was
structuring it because inherently by
being a war correspondent you're at war
and you're at home and yet war in your
home in your ward at home you know we
weren't covering one specific story and
so again for me that's why getting
inside of her head and trying to
understand how these war zones were
progressively affecting her over time in
that you know as as the film crescendos
towards the end you know she's she's
suffering more and more from alcoholism
in PTSD and and and pushing that limit
you know more and more despite every
single neon sign blaring stop stop stop
she kept going it's really incredible
and also the amount of access you you
give us to everything that's going on in
her head especially between you and
Robyn's performance I was wondering when
you first signed on was she just at the
top of your list from the beginning or
did you ever have to envision another
actor in that role she was always at the
top of my list she came to a screening
in my last documentary city of ghosts
and we got along quite well we had
breakfast the next morning and she sort
of came after the role as if you know
his memory going after an article she
had such passion for this film and the
story and for for Murray but also such
an incredible understanding of who she
was we both wrote each other essays of
who was Marie Colvin after this
breakfast and it's amazing how similar
they both were and it just was so clear
after reading it that this was my Marie
and we said about yeah going on this
really intense journey and gaining the
trust of her friends and her colleagues
and and in preparing for this role and
you know she did an incredible
incredible job I really wanted somebody
who's gonna get their hands dirty
whose didn't get in the trenches with me
and she did that and in spades she
really just I mean a physical
transformation and her voice it's it's
really astounding as she completely
loses
self in this part yeah I mean you know
she worked for months and months and
months with a dialect coach you know
it's not an easy accent you know she's
obviously from she's British actress
from from London and and you know Marie
is from Long Island and had this sort of
whiskey tone and and and this you know
lower octave and but she also
transformed physically you know she
studied Murray how she moved how she
held tension and her neck and her back
and how she you know splayed her hands
when she dissed ickle ated and she
studied Murray Murray with a with a
dancer and with his dancer sort of again
tried to learn how she moved and spent
many many weeks doing that she had a
tutor to try to understand you know the
geopolitical context that we were you
know venture into and so she really you
know did an incredible job preparing one
of the interesting things that I read in
the press notes that I really wanted to
ask you about was Jamie Dornan plays
Paul and Paul was on set at the
beginning I believe if I read this
correctly and he actually gave Jamie
notes the beginning of the shoot so as a
director how did that make you feel were
you did you kind of Usher him in to be
able to do that or are you like you know
you can hold back a little on the
director here oh yeah my my egos yeah is
that no I'm happily have somebody who
was there for real giving Jamie notes
Paul was like many people apprehensive
about the film I think he you know her
death is so raw for so many people still
you know this many years later so
getting him on board was was really
important and you know he wasn't kindly
helpful with with the final drafts of
the script anyway he was originally
supposed to come on four you know week
five days at the beating of shooting and
he ended up staying for every single day
for the entire shoot you know and and
some actors obviously would be reticent
about the character that they're
portraying being there he and Jamie got
along so well he was an inspiration not
just to Jamie but to me and to Rosman to
really every single person on this set
as a living breathing example of why we
were telling this story another thing
that I read in the notes we were talking
about earlier and I really want you to
speak to as much as you possibly can is
the idea of bringing in a certain group
of extras here also because whether it's
this movie or any movie I feel like
background performances also always go
very undervalued when that can take
someone out of a movie in a heartbeat
but here in particular I mean really
every single scene you have in this
movie everybody around your main
characters is having a really powerful
emotional experience so casting those
individuals seems like it is of the
utmost importance here yeah I mean I I'm
a control freak and I you know every
single detail every single frame every
single pixel on screen
you know mattered to me and we spent so
much time with every single Department
preparing to shoot the film and
authenticity both in her experience and
her portrayal of Murray but also the the
experience of being at war and being in
these war zones was really important to
me and a huge part of bringing that
alive
was casting non-actors refugees living
Jordan where we shot so that you know
when we're in Iraq when she's uncovering
a mass grave you know the women who are
wailing are real Iraqi women who are
reliving real trauma when we're in homes
near the besieged city of Homs in Syria
on our final assignment when she walks
into this you know shelter for women and
children the two women that she spoke to
were really from Homs they really were
in a shelter that was quite similar to
that one and they're telling their own
real stories and shedding real tears and
so when the second woman says I don't
just want this to be words on paper I
want the whole world to understand what
I'm going through
she's obviously speaking to Roz when
she's speaking to all of us and you know
there's a scene afterwards in which a
man brings in you know his young son who
ends up dying in this hospital
it's an incredibly emotional scene I
spent weeks and weeks finding that man
interviewing people for that role you
know he was also from Homs
he had a two-year-old nephew that was
shot off his shoulders by a sniper and
died in front of him so the trauma that
he in the emotion that he bought into
that room was you know almost unbearable
and there was a point at which Roz had
to sort of walk off set and you know she
she and she and I went out and talked to
her and she said you know is this okay
you know we're blurring these lines so
much I don't know is this right you know
are we exploiting this man and and I
said to her look this is what I do on a
daily basis in my documentaries you know
there's you have this human instinct to
want to give someone a hug or to give
them space but you know my job and our
job is to capture these moments and you
know he wouldn't be here if he didn't
want a story to be told
absolutely I can definitely understand
that given everything you just said I
mean between this movie and also your
documentaries you tackle a lot of very
tough subject matters so I imagine you
can't really kind of get your head above
it and take a breath of air while you're
making a movie but do you have a way to
kind of relax and detox and not not kind
of wallow in all of this and your free
time yeah I mean I've friends and loved
ones and I love to serve there's a lot
of things that I like to do but I you
know I also care deeply about mm-hmm the
films I make and the stories that I tell
and I think it's a huge privilege and a
huge honor to be able to do so and also
to be able to jump into a world every
couple years and explore that world yes
is such a privilege I greatly appreciate
that passion and drive and I'm very
thankful we have a movie like this I
meant what I said earlier guys go check
out a private war you won't regret it
Matthew huge congratulations again and a
thank you for coming into the studio
today good luck with everything here on
out guys thank you for watching this
interview as always like and share it
and stay tuned for more collateral in
you